everyone how's everybody doing i hope
you're doing fine
i'm doing okay so that's good today
we're going to talk about
extinction the extinction of man
so i hope i'm dressed appropriately
right for the occasion okay let me tell
you what i'm going to talk about give
you a quick outline here
okay i'm going to talk a little bit
about profits of doom
some of the profits that we've had
throughout time going to do a little
brief review of them
i'm going to ask uh important question
whether extinction is
a part of science should we be
discussing
this is rational science should we be
discussing extinction at all
i mean is this a topic that concerns
science
extinction 101 versus 102 i'll get on
that
a little well put you up to date on that
uh past extinctions we need to know a
little bit of what happened in the past
and uh then we got to figure out what
the mechanism for man's extinction
is going to be if there's ever going to
be an extinction
of the human race okay so that in a
nutshell
is what i'm going to cover okay
and let's begin with the prophets you
know and uh here's a poll that they ran
i got this out of the wikipedia and uh
2012 20 countries 14 of people believe
the world will end
in their lifetime i thought that was a
big number i can't find hardy
anybody who thinks that it's going to
end in within their lifetime but
yeah i guess uh i'm one of those even
though i didn't i was not included in
the poll
six percent of people in france and 22
in the united states
so apparently there's more people in the
united states that believe the world's
going to end or
within their lifetime more pessimistic
maybe
more realistic which one uh
in the uk 2015 23 apocalypse likely to
occur
in their lifetime compared to 10 of
experts
from the global challenges foundation so
here you have the
experts who study extinction say only 10
of them believe
that there's going to be an extinction
whereas 23 percent of the
population in the uk has been
told to think that it's going to happen
within their lifetime
what are the uh causes well
uh belief in the apocalypse lower rate
of education
lower incomes and those under 35 those
are the people who believe that
uh well i don't know if apocalypse
refers to the biblical
version or whether it's just going to
happen if it's about going to happen i
don't think i qualify
for those under 35 not anymore
but maybe i qualify for the lower rate
of education
uh general public what are the causes uh
nuclear war everybody thinks of nuclear
war we're going to destroy
each other okay that's i think the
number one probably or
it's up there with the with the best of
them right another one could be climate
change
uh experts they believe it's going to be
artificial intelligence we're going to
create a
eyes uh you know some monster
some frankenstein and he's going to wipe
us out
okay that's what the experts say um an
experiment
run amok um
three percent of uk and sixteen percent
of the us don't
believe in uh biblical uh
causes or uh prophecies
uh the last judgment right um
revelation et cetera right one to two
to three percent in the us and uk that
zombies
and aliens are gonna cause our
extinction zombies
okay people believe i think they've been
watching too much tv that's what i think
okay um let me get
organized here a little bit
give me a second
yeah uh here are some of the profits
in the past from like the year zero
to the year um what is it the end of the
19th century okay these are
different prophets and institutions
organizations that predicted the end of
man
okay you can see there's quite a few few
of them
and uh all these people primarily all
these people
thought the extinction was going to be
due for uh
as a result of biblical reasons okay so
they they simply try to interpret the
bible
and um and that's what they
projected onto the future okay and
usually they projected it for
the next hundred years or even imminent
and that sort of thing okay
so they they had this idea that uh
the bible was telling them something
that there was a prediction
in there um 20th century
here's a list of those people and now we
start to change
a little bit there's not only biblical
reasons
included in among these people but now
since we have more information about the
universe
people are thinking now in more
cosmic terms uh specifically accidents
you know uh cosmic accidents of some
kind
and uh in the 21st century
this is the last 20 years the ones on
the left
they think that it's going to happen
anytime soon
that it's going to happen within our
lifetime probably
the ones on the right you have those who
say well it's going to happen in the
21st century
and others say it's going to happen in
anywhere from the 22nd to the 23rd
century
and yet others uh propose that it's
going to happen you know maybe 100
million years 900
million years or who knows when and
everyone
everyone everyone is thinking along the
same lines they're all saying
look it's going to be a global
catastrophic uh
accident some catastrophe of some kind
so everybody's thinking in terms of
catastrophes they can't think of
anything
else and here you have a
listing let me get myself back in here
here you have a listing of um
of some of the biblical causes first
uh if you go to the good book you'll
find apocalypse millennium
antichrist he's gonna come back or or
he's just never left i guess
christ will come back okay no uh level
type flood you know uh god rains
40 days and 40 nights it just floods the
planet
water world something like that
planetary alignment some people
that's where the astrologers come in
they say look you got this planetary
alignment that's the end of us for
whatever reason
okay war okay wars been around for a
while people
when they saw war and disease they
always thought
also that could be the end of the world
judgment day obviously
jesus god everybody the devil everyone
comes over and says look it's
it's over for you guys we're gonna we're
gonna take some north and other south
[Laughter]
uh biblical interpretation years since
creation you say oh
six thousand years after the day of
creation that's when it's gonna happen
simply because the bible says so or
that's the interpretation
and you have people also uh talking
about in the second millennium and
again for biblical reasons that the
second coming of christ and that sort of
thing okay
so people are thinking along those lines
either catastrophic accidents the people
you could call
scientists and then the other people who
believe in
biblical prophecies essentially that's
what it comes down to
uh and here are the catastrophes
catastrophes
uh what do they propose well uh since
the 14th century since the black death
so many people died
uh people are thinking about the you
know diseases
and they probably happened even before
then um i'm sure that if you go to the
age of the romans you had uh um
smallpox ravaged towns and cities
they probably thought it was the end of
the world as well these are some of the
documented
things that we find out there comet
earthquake nuclear holocaust that's
one of the number ones in the 20th
century and still is okay
evil aliens they're going to invade us
they're already here asteroid hits the
earth
okay i guess people in the past never
thought about the
rock destroying the earth ever since
we've
located some of these rocks out there
that came into the popular
folklore as well you know
supernova gamma-ray again you have to
know a little more about the universe to
be able to come up with these ideas and
people in the past didn't have this
pandemic that's been around climate
change that's a new one very powerful
one a lot of people
making the uh talk
circuits talking about climate change
and how we have to stop
destroying the environment that sort of
thing increasing solar
brightness co2 starvation ais again you
know
peak oil some people say we're going to
run out of oil and then we're all dead
for whatever reason they never explain
the mechanism they just say peak oil
when it's
over we don't have energy to run the
world and that's it that's all they say
how we're gonna die we don't know we
don't have the mechanism the
step-by-step
mechanism running out of water uh
running out of arable land
volcanoes been popular all the way since
the permian everybody says you know
permian
uh synapses died because of
volcanoes volcanic activity in fact some
propose that even for the cretaceous
um fewer children we're going to have
fewer children
and we are having fewer children
proportionally to
to our total population so we're not
growing as well
uh as much how that's going to end up in
extinction i guess they're saying well
if we keep having less and less and less
and less people
less kids right eventually it's going to
whittle down to
no no population at all i guess that's
what the in the back of their minds
black hole cia experiment run amok
et's post humanism you know uh we're
gonna
upload our souls onto the internet
something uh that is very similar to
what they had in the old days where you
go to
heaven well this is more or less
internet heaven you know you upload your
soul you don't need your body anymore
that sort of thing okay um
what do i propose why am i different
than all these people i mean you could
say well bill
all you're doing is just you're just
another uh chicken little out there uh
saying uh the sky is falling you know
we've heard that before we we've seen it
over and over again
well but you won't find it anywhere uh
wikipedia wherever you go you'll you
won't find my theory whatsoever you got
to come here because you won't see it
anywhere else
and so that's what i'm going to talk
about today and so here's my two
proposals i'm saying uh we have what is
called a
mass extinction and a background
extinction what is a mass extinction
i define it as the disappearance of a
food chain chain um
i highlighted food and that gives you an
idea where i'm going with this i'm
saying we're
uh since i say that humans will die
because
of it in a mass extinction it's going to
be because
of food something related to food okay
and i'm saying that's how
mass extinctions happened in the past so
i'm
projecting that to the future and
background extinction
i don't think we're going to die in a
background extinction background
extinction is the disappearance of a
single species
meaning we disappear all alone and all
the other animals continue
like in the case of neanderthal i don't
think that's going to happen to us
now we're going to die in a mass
extinction we're going to die in the
extinction of the mammals all mammals
will die
with us okay we're gonna take them down
with us we're gonna take them to heaven
okay and uh so that's
in a nutshell what i'm proposing and uh
what this takes is two two kinds of
people today essentially all these
notions that people have out there you
have um
the people who think that we're never
gonna die uh
usually those are biblical people in
general
and they think that somehow god
designated us
as the gardener of eden and so uh
we're kind of like gods ourselves so
we're immortal we live forever
and that's because god chose we're the
chosen ones we're the chosen animal the
chosen mammal
so to speak right and uh we have
intelligence that's that's what he gave
us god gave us this intelligence so
you know we're going to use it
and again we were created to take care
of the garden
and all the animals are subservient to
us
they were made for our use either to eat
or to have watch them at the circus or
whatever
whatever and then there's the other
people who say well humans will go
extinct
someday you know like way somewhere in
the future
like i i don't have to worry about it
you know because it's going to happen
sometime in the future
and so they put it off it's like it's
not going to happen today because if you
ask anyone who says it's going to happen
in a few months first they'll say
probably it's not going to happen
and then they won't have a mechanism
anyway they can't give you a mechanism
for why it's going to happen in one year
in two years and five years
okay so it's like it's just their
opinion they just
say maybe they might have a biblical
reason or maybe a catastrophic
reason they might say well the comet's
going to hit the earth or there's going
to be a supernova
oh yeah maybe there won't be and then
what we live forever
so that's that's more or less uh the
argument there
okay um where does this take us
first uh we're gonna decide whether
extinction
is a part of science is
do we need extinction as part of science
i mean is is it a part of science does
it have anything to do with science
well uh you know uh we define
uh science as
explanations rational explanations
well you can only explain something
that's happened
uh phenomenon that's already occurred so
the question is
you know the as far as i know the
extinction of humans has not happened
yet
so if it has not happened yet there's
nothing to explain and if there's
nothing to explain well
how can it be a part of science so we
have to put in the proper context
what's the context the context is that
we're going to explain
not human extinction we're going to
explain
extinction we're going to have a
mechanism for extinction
specifically i'm going to deal with mass
extinction and we do have those
that have happened in the past there's
uh especially you know the five major
extinctions
and that's what we have to explain how
did those animals die
why did they disappear what happened to
them so we're going to explain first and
foremost
uh past extinctions consummated
extinctions
and then what we're going to do we're
going to extrapolate that to man
that's the idea here and you know again
you're saying
because i had a discussion the other day
with one of my sons my youngest son
and uh we don't look see eye to eye on
this issue
and uh he says that if you projected to
the future
you're not talking about science anymore
because now you're talking about
something that hasn't happened
that's his argument my argument is that
what i'm what i'm proposing is that we
cannot
avoid extinction like
you know the dinosaurs or the synapses
or the uh
archosaurs none of those could avoid
extinction
so i'm saying it's an inevitable thing
inevitable
thing that will happen and so
i have to explain why it will happen and
why it's unavoidable why we can't do
anything about it
that's how i say it fits into science
because i'm explaining
on the one hand past extinctions i'm
confirming them by saying look
if man with all his intelligence cannot
avoid this same mechanism that killed
all species in the past
then that means first we in a way we
have a little assurance that that's
probably what happened in the past
that's one issue but that's a question
of belief
but the other one is that if we can't do
anything about it we can come
can't come up with an antidote
that means that it's going to happen to
us also
so it's like if we're looking at it from
the future and say look humans
have died because they could not avoid
death and this is the reason this is
what will cause
them to go extinct and they can't do
anything about it
that's how i put it into science okay
that's that's the logic that's the
rationale okay so uh
so yeah i'm saying it is part of science
under
those under that context and uh
so again i don't think it's a prediction
in that sense i'm not saying
and i i haven't never done so saying
look uh humans will this
the last human will die on the 5th of
may
of uh the year 2030. no
i'm not an astrologer i don't have that
kind of information
i don't purport to have that kind of
information which is a lot of what all
these
previous uh prophets uh
always came up with they said oh the
according to the bible if i do my
calculations right
this is the exact date of the extinction
of man and they had no reason no no
other than the coming of christ that's
it he's coming down that day and he's
taking everybody out that's it
so so it was an issue of faith here i'm
talking about something else i'm talking
about a mechanism i'm saying we cannot
avoid
when exactly it will happen i have no
idea all i can do is
with my own gut feeling say what might
happen sooner it might happen later
okay that's all i can say and again
that's my belief
right here i'm only concerned about the
mechanism okay
what is going to cause it and why we
cannot avoid it
those are the two issues i'm going to
concentrate on okay
um we have in our discussion with my son
he said the only guarantee prediction is
death every prediction
that can be guaranteed out there is
somehow related to death like the death
of a star if
we're going to talk about the death of a
star the end point
of its cycle so only
we can only say that all cycles end
except
of course under the rope model you know
the the universe okay
and um before i continue with that we
i've got to clarify
that we must explain uh extinction 101
before we
uh begin attacking extinction 102. a lot
of people like to put comments and ask
questions
and they go directly to 102. no way
at least i'm not going to pay attention
to any of those questions or comments
if you want to come into extinction you
got to go through extinction 101.
what's extinction 101 past
animals we have to explain how the past
animals died first you got to tell me
how you think
the dinosaurs died how the permian
synapses how the uh
triassic archosaurs or whatever you got
to tell me how the animals in the past
died
if you cannot tell if you don't have a
full proof
mechanism for how they died you know
nothing about extinction
much less can you talk about human
extinction
which is a subset so uh
again uh whatever i say today you got to
go through extinction 101 first
okay at least from my point of view i'm
not i'm going to ignore
all comments or or questions that go
directly to man
i don't care about man i'm talking about
extinction you don't know anything about
extinction you know nothing about the
extinction of man
period we're done okay so that's the way
i i'm gonna handle that okay so be aware
if you want to put a comment
please begin by saying how past ex
extinctions happen how animals in the
past died
okay um here's the uh
relativistic version of um
of the future okay and they say uh
there's been a big bang okay and that
goes on forever i guess
well not true now they have this notion
that after the big bang
all matter just keeps uh bloating away
okay just uh
separates and eventually it turns into
something that looks like this
here it comes give it a second okay you
have this ball that's expanding
i guess expanding through space
the balloon is expanding okay that's the
notion that relative
mathematical physics in general believes
in all the mathematical physics
physicists believe in this kind of thing
there's going to be simply
a a continuation of the explosion that
began
almost 14 billion years ago it's going
to expand until
everything becomes so light
you know the result there's no density
and uh
it's a rare rare uh universe where you
see
very little matter uh per volume
okay and so we just kind of
whittle away or disappear into
nothingness
that's the notion they have
now under the rope model we have a
totally different
version it's uh we have a single
closed-loop thread
in all space that's all there is
and this thread is what turns into
everything
you know it turns into atoms
and the ropes that interconnect all
atoms
atoms cannot convert into empty space
empty space cannot convert
into atoms therefore the universe has
always been there and
it will always be there when we're gone
okay
so uh there is no conversion
of matter into nothing which is what
these people are proposing
but then they define nothing as made of
particles as we discussed last time so
their argument is totally irrelevant i
mean until they can tell us what nothing
is what space is
and uh hopefully it's not made of
particles
because if it's made of particles you
can't say it turned into nothing that
sounds a lot like something
and the only issue there is you know
what contours each
particle we're done you know that they
if they can't answer that question they
don't have a theory
okay um so let's go with the extinction
what is it that we have to explain
as far as past extinctions extinction
101
right yeah we got that okay this is what
we got to explain
okay now you may not agree with this you
may say well where did they get this
uh what we have here is a graph of uh
millions of years on the bottom you can
see that and you have the ordovician the
silurian uh
devonian carboniferous etc you have all
these different
eras okay ages and
uh those are the big five extinctions
how did they come up with this
well the paleontologists go into the
rock and they find different layers
and they say well this layer is a
million years old this one is 10 million
years old this one's 100 million years
old
and so on because that's how long it
takes for
rock formation within those layers they
find bones
and they said oh look throughout this
period i don't know 10 20 30 million
years we had this animal
and suddenly it disappeared we don't
find his bones anymore
and uh and for a mass extension you find
that
a whole family a whole order disappeared
suddenly
a whole bunch of animals disappeared
what i call uh
a um a food chain
okay that's where i get the notion of a
food chain what this appears in a mass
extinction
is an entire food chain and the one that
runs parallel to it usually the smaller
animals they don't know what's going on
suddenly the big guys are gone
that's essentially what a mass
extinction is and these are the five
most important ones but as you can see
there are other
peaks there so you gotta explain a mass
extinction in general
what is causing these periodic mass
extinctions
that's the question we want to address
and that's the first one we gotta
answer because if we find a cookie
cutter we can apply it to man and say oh
if this animal died because of this and
this one also died because then this
other one died because of this
can we escape that same mechanism
see what i'm saying that's that's the
notion that i'm gonna
talk about okay that's the one i'm gonna
propose okay
uh so what do i propose well i propose
this i propose that you know throughout
history
uh life history of life on earth right
we had different land plants
major uh categories of plants
uh we went from the bryophytes to the
pterodites uh
pteridophytes to uh gymnosperms and
angiosperms that we have today
and uh each one of these groups
dominated the landscape
during millions of years and then they
gave way and some other
uh type of plan took over like in the
case of the ferns you know they
dominated the landscape
uh throughout the uh permian and then
uh in the jurassic and the cretaceous uh
we have the
gymnosperms take over primarily the
cycads first and with the ginkgos
and eventually the conifers so the this
is the trend
that we see uh in the rock okay this
this is uh the varieties we find inside
the layers of rock and also the
quantities we find within the layer of
rock
and as we reach towards the end well we
see that
the angiosperms begin to displace the
the gymnosperms
so what am i saying i'm saying each era
was dominated by
big area right it was dominated by a
certain
type of plant and what do you think
would happen
if um if the plant suddenly disappears
not suddenly but gradually disappears
what would happen to the animals that
forged a uh long-term relationship with
these plants
well you would think that their numbers
would be decreasing decreasing
decreasing and at some point
they're gone the animals are gone the
plants continue a little
further and then they're gone too
because they're displaced by
more modern plants or new plants that
mother nature
invents and and spawns okay
okay here's another vision of that same
thing okay
and again you can see that breaking them
down
in big chunks so that we get the big
picture that's the point of this
and you can see we have the age of ferns
again around the carboniferous permian
etc
and they continued like we had seed
firms all the way to uh
at least the jurassic i think and um
eventually these uh ferns disappear
and they were pushed aside by the
conifers okay
uh just the different families of
conifers they
dot the landscape there were no grasses
at the time
and about maybe 150 million years ago
that's when the flowering plants started
muscling aside the conifers
okay so as these trends
uh made their way the animals that
forged relationships with those plants
with those major categories i think they
disappeared as well
one of the arguments people raise is
they say well
you know animals will switch
foods instead of eating this they'll eat
that
well i don't know um take a rabbit
uh you give him lettuce he'll eat it
he'll eat some grass
they'll eat these things you give them
ferns
they don't eat they don't eat that in
fact i think it kills them
and if you give them pine leaves they
don't eat that either
and they can't switch overnight and say
any more than you can i mean for that
matter do it with yourself you eat
lettuce right uh can you go in there and
replace that with
pine leaves pine bristles or pine cones
can you switch your diet like as your
stomach ready to receive that
new plant i mean plants or plants or
plants right i mean what the hell
does it matter no it does matter
and uh what i'm saying here is that if
you have the conifers displace the ferns
and the dinosaurs are feeding on
conifers in general
all types of counterfairs and they
radiate
together with these conifers as the
conifers eventually come to an end
in other words they start becoming fewer
and fewer and fewer
not only a number but also in variety
well you have fewer niches for the
dinosaurs to
radiate and they start coming down as
well you know some species start
vanishing here and there that's the
background extinction rate
and eventually there's a moment where
there's a collapse a
relative relative swift geological
geologically speaking right collapse
it suddenly you know dawns on them that
they cannot switch at the last moment to
other foods
first of all because they've been
graduating
gradually been adjusting their numbers
to the available food supply and there's
no need to change their food
as this process is happening they just
adjust their numbers to the
dwindling food supply that's all they do
it's not like you know
the food disappears all of a sudden you
know the the plants
uh are disappearing they're being
muscled aside by new plants
and the animals that are in this island
eating this type of food all they see is
a shrinking island and they just adjust
their numbers to the shrinking island
that's it
now why do plants disappear climate
change maybe
uh maybe the other plants are displacing
them they're
muscling them aside uh no
the reason plants disappear and again i
give this
uh this uh little uh
vision you go back to the cambrian 542
million years ago okay
and you look ahead okay you can predict
now because we know
what happened so now you can kind of
predict from the cambrian
starting line looking forward okay we're
assuming the cambrian is essentially
when the
animals came to be apparently they they
were already
in the pre-cambrian but that's academic
uh you look ahead what do you expect
well you expect plants to die
big orders big chunks of uh
types of plants right you expect them to
die periodically because that's what
happened
why did it happen was it because they
were displaced
well i think there's a more important or
more fundamental reason and that is that
plants undergo a cycle
of from birth to death just like any
other living entity
and uh what happens throughout this time
they lose first their genetic diversity
and towards the end
of the plants life near the end of these
orders right uh what happens is their
population pyramid overturns okay they
live longer okay they have
fewer offspring okay they lay out
fewer seeds okay and eventually they
whittle out
you can find some examples like in the
redwoods in california
they don't grow by seeds anymore in fact
they put out very few seeds that are
actually worth anything now they grow by
um by um you know plant the the tree
dies
it's called vegetative growth and
another uh
clone comes out of that tree so
a lot of these plants grow these these
this way
today and i think that's how you can
spot how old those plants are
by seeing how many of them have
vegetative growth
versus those plants that have seed
growth that grow
as a result of seed and pollination and
etc
okay so plants uh are expected to die
if they have their cycle their long-term
cycle they live
a lot longer than animals for sure and
uh
as these plants follow this cycle
eventually they come to a dead end which
is
when their population pyramid overturns
and their genetic diversity disappears
okay
and so this is this is where i'm going
with that that's
my the theory that i'm proposing okay
and um here's another
vision of that not so much with plants
but here we have what happens in the
seas
okay this is a big picture that i
propose for what's happening in the seas
okay
and again what you see that in the
paleozoic
paleozoic it was governed by the
trilobites
uh when you go to mesozoic you've got
the
ammonites this is the age of ammonites
and today ever since the mammals came
around
what we see in the seas we see the age
of krill
okay and the krill are now dying we have
uh plankton dying on us massively we
have less plankton out there you can
check the articles that are coming out
and krill eats plankton so do whales uh
they are
filter feeders and um the plankton are
dying
um crew is dying uh you have uh fewer
and fewer krill
and that's the bottom of the food chain
and so when the bottom of the food chain
disappeared at the end of the paleozoic
which was the end of the permian
uh we had all these animals die in the
seas
and the uh new that niche was taken over
by the ammonites essentially okay
so there's always some crossover the
ammonites took over that niche they
started diversifying growing in numbers
etc
and essentially the mosasaurs you know
they
ammonites and guess what uh towards the
end the plankton disappeared a lot of
the plankton dye atoms uh
for eminifera uh disappeared at the end
of the
cretaceous and so did some of these uh
fil
these uh probably filter feeders right
like uh the ammonites and that was the
bottom of the food chain that's what the
uh
mosasaurs ate and some of these guys
were big you know uh that's why i put
a big ammonite there because some of
them were like six feet tall
so a six feet radius okay um
sorry uh diameter so uh some of these
ammonites though
i think they've found some in canada
just gigantic ammonites
and so they're not like little uh bugs
they're crawling on the ground no they
were monsters some of them were monsters
and uh moses ours ate some of at least
the uh
mid-sized ones that ended up the
cretaceous
so i'm saying that it all has to do with
a food chain
food chain disappears that's a mass
extinction
okay okay
so uh how do we go to humans with all
this
i'm saying humans are going to die
because of food and so let's get started
on humans
remember you got to do extinction 101
first then we can get to what we're
going to do now which is extinction 102.
that's
special that's human extinction and
again it's a
projection for the future based on the
idea that we cannot
avoid the same mechanism
that all these animals in the past could
not avoid even if they had technology
and intelligence they wouldn't have been
able to avoid it
and that's what we have today we have
foresight we have intelligence we have
technology
none of those are antidotes to what i'm
going to propose which is the collapse
of our economy okay so uh here we start
we start by saying that the world
population
this is our global population human
population has been steadily dropping
the growth rates have been steadily
dropping since 1963.
that was the last time we had but i
think it was 2.3 2.2 or 2.3
uh growth rate and since then it's been
steadily dropping this steadily is
crucial here
we had for example in the 14th century
we had the bubonic plague
wiped out maybe a third to a half of the
population of europe those are the
numbers that are kicked around
a lot of that information is taken from
the little towns and cities
they go to the books how many people
died and they get an idea that
a lot of people died in those days that
was the bubonic plague
black death etc and uh population
recovered it took like really two
like 200 years to where to recover but
the population
recovered despite the fact that so many
people died
and why because we were still young we
were young species
today we are an old species very old
species
and you say bill you're crazy what do
you mean what do you mean an old species
we're
young we were only about 200 300 000
years old right
mother nature doesn't count youth
by how many times the earth goes around
the sun not for
this kind of thing not for species for
species it goes in a different direction
for species mother nature looks at how
much
genetic diversity you have and we've
essentially lost all our genetic
diversity we are all clones
essentially or getting there very
quickly
if you take a japanese you take an
african you take
russian you take a south america north
american australian
you check their dna we are clones
essentially anyone who you marry
is from a genetic point of view either
your sister or your brother
doesn't matter it's a different
so-called race
why because our grandparents our
great-grandparents went through the same
sifting process specifically diseases
we all whether you were in japan in
china and
india wherever you were it doesn't
matter your great grandfathers
were able to overcome uh especially the
childhood diseases that
killed half of the children born they
killed them before the age of five
and here now all these kids could grow
up they were not dead anymore
uh and have children of their own and so
that's how the population started
growing
especially in the 19th century that's
when the human population
took a big jump and it continued all the
way until 1963.
and after that no now we're declining uh
we have fewer kids for many different
reasons i'm not going to
go through all of them but we are
declining no doubt about we're
we're growing at a slower we're still
growing but growing at a slower rate
that's the point okay
so our curve is you know like concave
it's
it's getting to that asymptote okay to
that straight line we're going to reach
a
plateau and from then on it's going to
be
downhill and we only have three
possibilities after that if we go
continue going up we go straight ahead
more or less up and down
stay stable you know for just give you a
number nine billion people on the planet
and we
oscillate around nine billion sometimes
more sometimes less but always around
there or we go
south we go down to extinction and i'm
saying we go down to extinction not only
that we will go down but we will go down
swiftly
vertically almost okay so it's not going
to be
a slow decline no because uh what's
going to take over
is economics it's going to overrule
uh our slow descent into what is known
as a background extinction
we would die like for example the
neanderthals or
wooly which died in background
extinctions we won't die that way we
we go out with a bang okay that's my
point of view
i'm gonna in other words it's a
geologically
sudden extinction and with us we'll go
all the mammals
okay um so uh
here are uh a little evidence
persuade you convince you a little
religion
on uh a fact that is that we don't have
that much
genetic diversity among the human race
as compared to other animals at least
and here you have two
statements one from the wikipedia says
the genetic differences among human
groups are relatively small
and then here we have a society group an
association that
does a little studying okay on the
subject matter and genetics
so human genetic diversity is
substantially lower
than that of many other species
including our nearest evolutionary
relative the chimpanzee remember
chimpanzee there's very few of them on
the planet
and they live in these groups uh
they're called troops you go to a troop
maybe 100
chimps and they're like you know i guess
they have sex among
each other they have more genetic
diversity the entire than the entire
human race
you see how can that possibly be these
guys are located they
they have sex among themselves and they
have more genetic diversity in the
entire human race
almost eight billion people on different
parts of the world with different
climates different environments how can
that possibly be
and again it's that we um we got rid of
all our genetic diversity
through inner inner inbreeding we've had
a
successful life and we've conquered
diseases
so we essentially are all clones today
that's essentially my argument and uh
here's a
famous case of john calhoun uh he had he
put some
mice in a uh
closed in a little uh small room
essentially
and uh he let him grow he put four pairs
of mice that's all four pairs four
couples
and each one got his girl each one of
them uh
male mice he got his own girl they
formed their little uh
family and the family started growing uh
in a few months they had two thousand
mice in there all came from the same
for uh fathers grandfathers right
and eventually the uh the colony ended
up in extinction
they were given all the food they wanted
all the water they had no diseases
no predators and they turned the corner
and they all went down
and ended up in extinction and he did
this at least 25 times this is uh
utopian universe number 25 i don't know
if it was his last one but
from 1947 to 1970s early 1970s he did a
total i think of 25
experiments first with rats and then
with mice all of them ended up in the
same way
okay besides the fact that the
rats and mice went nuts and
he's probably one of the first person to
produce homosexuality in the lab
a lot of the mice and a lot of the rats
became homosexual towards the end
sounds like he's describing our society
in great measure so you should look up
john calhoun
and his experiments okay he was a
psychologist
okay uh yesterday at night i was
watching
uh morgan freeman and uh
something came up which got my attention
i said i'm gonna use this
tomorrow and morgan freeman was looking
into god
the existence of god he's doing he did a
research on that
and i'm watching that to find out what
he's got to say about god
and it's an interesting thing that he
goes to the middle east
and he goes see this lady who's an
expert at her subject apparently and
she talks about these monks that still
try to imitate
jesus christ and they go to the desert
and they subject themselves to
starvation you know essentially for five
days they don't eat
and so uh morgan freeman asks well why
did they do that
i mean why why do you want to punish
yourself like that
and she says because they they want to
take themselves to the
limit okay and this is their discussion
okay so
morgan freeman says uh the monks living
here today put themselves through the
same temptation jesus
faced as their own test of faith they
venture out to the nearby caves
and fast for five days a week so we
asked the lady
why fasting and she says fasting
is getting yourself to a point of crisis
because when people are in crisis
that's when they're really dangerous if
their belly's full
they're happy then they are not
dangerous
but when you're weak and hungry you will
do many
bad things
okay so for all those people who think
that uh we're gonna be friends after
we get rid of government and the whole
thing collapses and finally we're free
of taxation and all that stuff
think again we're gonna replace one evil
with a much greater evil
and that's going to be starvation and
during starvation people do
what you say dangerous things okay we're
going to be killing each other we're
going to eat be
eating each other first we're going to
eat whatever's out there all mammals
will disappear forget it
there's not that many mammals out there
to feed us anyways but
i'm sure someone's gonna take care of
those uh some people say well how about
the lost tribes out there you know
they're gonna survive because they're
not part of our economic system these
people
have mental problems that's what i say
you know i mean
either they don't do any research or
they don't have a capacity for reasoning
the lost tribes are the first that are
going to die
they're the first to go okay uh why is
that
well because there are no lost drives to
begin with you know we have these
satellites unless you believe in the
flat earth okay
we have these satellites um and they can
locate a match box in the middle of the
jungle
you know nobody's lost on the planet
anymore we found everybody everybody's
found
lost and found everybody's found and
whoever's out there we know where they
are
and when you're desperate you're hungry
and you know a lot of people are just
going to be thinking
i'm going to go to that island do some
justice
like feed myself okay and you might go
there to feed yourself on the animals
first and when that's over well then
you're going to fight have to fight the
engines the natives
and you're probably going to be in
better situation than they are you're
probably going to have a gun you
probably even know that the world's
coming to an end
whereas they don't uh you know in fact
there's an island a couple years ago um
in the indian ocean uh it's managed by
india
and they have to protect the natives
there because people go down there and
even now every now and then especially
um priests and so on they want to
convert the
indians and the indians just kill them
whoever comes to the end they kill them
because they
they're very hostile okay and they want
to keep their island free of visitors
and the indian government protects them
they protect them because they say look
we want to
keep these people like they are they
they live in peace there etc
well imagine when the government ceases
to exist
you know that island's going to be
overrun and the natives are going to be
you know roasted you know in the fire
so forget about uh amish the amish are
going to be the first to go
you know mennonites and amish because
right now they have protection
who protects them well for example in
the united states you have you know
pennsylvania
ohio indiana all that area is full of
amish
and they have this protection from whom
do they have weapons or they have
cannons and
ways of defending themselves no the us
government protects it
okay and uh and the law protects them so
they have both
military physical protection police etc
and on the other hand they also have
legal protection
well when government's gone all that's
gone and here they have these
great farms these beautiful farms and no
weapons to defend themselves in fact
they don't believe in defending
themselves they don't believe in
violence
and they probably don't even know what's
going on outside their walls
maybe they do i don't know but whether
they believe what's
going on out there they don't they don't
care about all that stuff anyways
so people are just going to overrun
their farms and kill every amish
alive we're going to skin them alive
okay
so forget it the amish are going to need
protection you know like
you need protection like al capone would
say you need protection
and there's got to be no protection of
governments gone
so let's find out how government's going
to be gone okay
here's the uh chain of uh money
okay this is what runs our our modern
world
okay essentially this is a snapshot you
have consumers
they receive salaries and they spend it
in the market
uh among other things right there's
other stores etc but i'm just gonna
concentrate on the food
because food you know if you don't have
a computer you can still breathe
uh we still have air that's not uh being
monopolized by anyone it looks like it
covers the entire planet so we don't
have
to fear uh lack of uh air uh water
it could be maybe uh market for sure if
because that's where you get your food
okay and for sure you cannot live
without food
which is very strange in a sense because
nobody has thought about
food as a mechanism for extinction we
we take food so much for granted but you
know how do we get food well we spend
money that we
got for the most part right from
salaries and wages
so we go to the market the market uh
asks the delivery guy to deliver
more uh food the delivery guy gets it
uh typically from a manufacturer who
packages
and man and process it or whatever and
the manufacturer gets it from the
producer that's the chain
of um of food and the chain of money
see all that's being held together by
money what happens when money disappears
well when that dollar that euro or
whatever disappears that chain is broken
and now that chain doesn't work anymore
and so what happens the consumer either
has no money or he has money but it's
worthless
so he can't go to the market the market
won't sell it to him because what is he
going to give the market
money if money is no more and
the delivery guy was going to request
the same thing he said well
the market says well give me some
deliveries and the delivery guy the
transportation guy says
well no because what are you going to
pay me with money
i mean money is no more money is
worthless all you got is uh
confetti okay that's all you got in your
hand
and the manufacturer is not going to
give it to the delivery guy and then the
producer is not going to give it to the
manufacturer
why will the producer produce if he
cannot make any money
he cannot um he cannot have
um what is it um
um what's the word um
uh well he cannot accumulate money okay
uh just blank my head there
anyways uh he cannot make any profits
that's what i want to say
so if he doesn't have any profits
because money is no more why is the
producer going to produce and give it to
the manufacturer and to the deliverer
into the market
that whole thing falls apart hopefully
you can understand that
we're assuming now okay we're we're
going to assume that money is no more
so far i haven't explained that okay i'm
just saying if
money is no more that whole chain
collapses
and if you don't understand that i can't
help you
uh give it a try go to the market see if
you can buy something without money
if they'll give you a carrot or a bag of
potatoes
unless you give them money some kind of
money
okay and if money is no more
if money is no more you have nothing to
give them
and it will not accept your blank hands
and say look we'll give it
we'll give you food anyways even though
they they do give out food for free in
some places okay
but in general you know you you have to
have money you got to go out there and
buy because
that's what the guy is in business for
to make a profit
okay so this is the issue i hope you
understand that much okay
before you go all emotional on me and
say oh you're crazy here
okay so let's keep that in mind you
gotta have money without money we're
dead
okay that's the issue okay
and uh so what happens if we have this
scenario okay
we have the employed fewer and fewer
employed and more and more unemployed
what do we use money for well we use
money to pay salaries
and that's where the whole thing starts
we give salary to the
employed guy and he goes out there and
buys from the market etc etc right just
like
i explained just a minute ago but what
happens when
it's the uh blue team that has fewer and
fewer
uh members and more in the red team
can we keep this up can we have 10
percent unemployment 20
30 40 50 unemployment can we do that
without the global economy crashing
can we have increasing increasing
unemployment
so that's the first thing you should
keep in mind okay that's where i'm going
with this
okay um
this is the big picture okay
we've had for the last 10
000 years you could say because before
that we were all hunter gatherers
essentially more hunter than gathers
uh 100 of our labor was dedicated to
procuring food that was it we were just
like any other animal in eden you know
all animals what do they
manage i mean every animal has an
economy
every animal is an economist what he
manages
because that's what economy is
management of resources
what is the resource that an animal
especially a wild animal right
uh manages well he manages his food
that's all he's worried about he's got
to fill his stomach
the next day or in two days or in three
days or in some amount of time
and so that's what we were for maybe 200
000 years
or more who knows but then about 10 000
years ago and again these numbers are
very general so
don't pin me on the numbers they're just
uh in general so that you get the big
picture
uh we started going into farming okay
and farming is that green uh
block there and the hunter gathering
sort of thing they started dying
so the orange one which is the hunter
gathering started dying
and what is increasing now is the
farming we started going into farming
first
into subsistence farming and then
eventually
we went into commercial farming
commercial farming brought in a new
thing called manufacturing and probably
some services as well
right and some people started making
you know maybe swords or spears or
weapons or
or tools and they or maybe furniture
ended or houses right and they started
doing that and
they started specializing and some
people
became strictly agriculturalists more of
them
worked in agriculture but there were
fewer people who worked either as
soldiers
or as or as builders of some kind
they they they did manufacturing of some
kinds of rudimentary
uh manufacturing well eventually uh
agriculture became so uh easy to do
especially at the
turn of the 19 from the 18th to the 19th
century
that's when we went through the
industrial revolution
and so agriculture we started
introducing machines into agriculture
and agriculture became much
easier to do less labor intensive
so agriculture started to die and
manufacturing started to
increase and we went like that at least
till world war
ii okay so all the way until world war
ii we can see how that blue little
block there the manufacturing block
started growing at the expense of
agriculture but uh i think it was 1979
and thereabouts
services overtook manufacturing as a
percentage of gdp in some countries
i think sweden was the first one
united states was among the first ones
also europe in general
but around that time you know uh
services right after world war
ii started taking over and eventually
caught up and surpassed manufacturing
well today most countries are the this
is global what you're seeing there but
some of the
most advanced countries which in in a
way are more important
to see because it's more relevant some
of the most advanced
nations they have like 85 percent
services and beyond
and only about 14 manufacturing and only
one percent of agriculture so even
though those blocks don't show that at
the end there
the service economy is much bigger in
advanced nations
and then you have that block of
unemployment and uh i made it big you
say why did you make it so big
well i made it big because what's
happened is we're having more
unemployment
in the world uh as we go to the cities
as we move to the cities
and one of the big chunks of that
unemployment that black that dark
unemployment
block there is that services
group services is masked
unemployment services is unemployment
okay service is a promise okay most
services at least as far as i can tell
if not all of them
are just promises you know what what is
insurance insurance is a promise
there's nothing there you know if you
had your eyes like god
looking at the planet from above what do
you see well you see what's constructed
if you want to know if germany is a
wealthy nation if sweden is a wealthy
nation
what do you look at well you look at
from the sky you say well
this is how much is constructed and this
is the standard of living etc
and what is a standard of living goods
that's what you see
okay now uh you don't see
the services services are things to be
performed in the future their promises
and you can't see the services
you know someone sings that's a service
what did he give you nothing you can't
see the scene
you can't see a barbering you know once
he cuts your hair that's it and the next
day he's got to get another client
that's different than you know
manufacturing a computer or something
solid like that or a food which is also
tangible
those are things you can see from the
sky you can see you know the
factories you can see the buildings you
can see the ships the
airplanes you can see the cotton fields
you can see all that stuff you can see
the the visible stuff is the tangible
stuff the intangible stuff
known as services that's fake that's a
fake economy and we're creating a lot of
that more and more every day
through the internet we're headed in
that direction when everybody just stays
at home does
home office and they do a little program
or a little game or whatever they do
and or provide a service the girls show
themselves
on youtube you know there's all kinds of
jobs out there today that
you know can disappear in two seconds
because we don't need them it's a luxury
economy a service economy
is a luxury economy you pay for whatever
service you want
as long as you have the money right and
and so you just pay
and you want to see this you pay you
want someone to cut your lawn
you pay you want the barber to shave you
or
cut your hair you pay you don't do it
yourself
and so we get into this luxury we're all
pharaohs
you know we just pay for all our slaves
to do stuff for us
you can't fix the electricity no problem
call the electrician can't
fix the uh the water leak called a
plumber
you don't do all that stuff you what do
you do you do programming or
whatever so so the issue is that
service economy is a luxury economy and
it's an inexistent
economy and a lot of it is tourism
you know in fact uh one of the big
things that happened with the kovid
virus is tourism suffered tremendously
you know hotels do we need hotels no
it's it proved that there we don't need
hotels
we don't need restaurants you can eat at
home that's luxury you say uh today i'm
going to spend some money i'm going to
go to
take the the frau the girl
whatever to the uh restaurant or we're
going to go on vacation take a trip on
the airplane go to
hawaii and go to a hotel you know so we
don't need all that
that's luxury okay so
um the
the um service economy
is a luxury economy and it's an economy
we don't need that's different than
neanderthals needing to kill some animal
to eat the next day that you need
otherwise you don't survive
services we can dispense with and we
showed here that even though
about 10 percent of services disappeared
around the world because of this
covid thing it's like yeah uh we fixed
it we just gave everybody
a little bit of money and we continue
going but it means we did not need it
absolutely needed
in fact probably when we come out of
this thing if if we ever do
uh people are going to do a lot of uh
home office they're just going to work
from their
homes and they won't need to travel by
airplane to the meeting
they'll just do meetings through the
internet because they're just going to
get used to that just like we're going
to be buying things through the internet
etc
so yeah the new world uh bodes terrible
for um for real stuff it's all going to
be
through the internet a lot of it big
percentage of it
and all that and a lot of the jobs are
going to be like that as well
and what is that it's all fake jobs it's
uh
how can i tell you that it's a fake job
it is
a fake job it's in you know a lot of
people will
dispute that right especially the narco
caps the
anarcho-capitalists uh but let me keep
going here
um a lot of people say well if the
uh global economy collapses governments
collapse money collapse there's no
problem
in fact it's good that's what they say
it's good you say what do you mean it's
good yeah it's good we get rid of
government governs taxing us
intervening in our transactions if we
can get government off our backs
man i can make my trade with with
whoever i want and i have all the
freedom
to do so no longer will i be able to
will i have to really have uh this these
eyes behind me staring at me saying hey
you need to give me 10 percent of that
you know mafia it's called government
it's mafia
yeah government goes out there with a
tax collector and a gun behind it you
know
tax collector comes in nice you don't
you don't give them the money
uh the guy behind them with a gun he
takes your present kills you or whatever
or steals it from you so yeah government
people especially today they they resent
government they say oh
government we got to get rid of
government yeah but when you get rid of
government you got rid of money that's
essentially what
getting rid of government means because
government produces money
okay and uh government regulates money
and yeah there's a lot of arguments that
you can
weasel out of that but um well i'm not
gonna get into
all those little details today but what
i'm saying is government collapses money
collapses there is no more money
okay aside from the fact that a lot of
utilities
um are government-run in different
countries of the world
and so that's going to be a problem
because suddenly you don't have any
water
electricity of government collapses okay
and that might also be a domino effect
where some poor countries fall first
then the next poor then get to the
richer countries and finally the whole
thing collapses
okay so uh the question is did uh
you know some people say well you know
i'm gonna do some bartering or whatever
with my neighbor and
we're just gonna be fine we're gonna be
great without government
well uh and a lot of these people
believe that the neanderthals you know
traded with us and they have all these
theories out there and some people get
that from there they say well you know
we traded all along you know we we
traded with the neanderthals and so on
and if uh if you go to some of these
paleontologists so-called
paleontologists they say yeah we
we've proven that we found some
seashells
uh that shouldn't have been in france
and we found them there so obviously
they were carrying these
seashells all the way from spain
to france and that means that they
traded them they they used it as a
bartering chest as money
that's what they're saying and so yeah
what can i say um
here's uh here's bartering uh the
neanderthal way
yeah the guy goes out there and uh
trades his wife
for maybe the uh um
the mammoth and his wife
i don't know i don't think so i don't
think this ever happened there was no
trade
in those days i cannot imagine someone
doing the service the
mediator saying hey joe you stay in your
cave
and what i'm gonna do i'm gonna get the
buffalo for you
are you gonna hunt it no no joey's gonna
uh johnny's gonna hunt the
buffalo he's gonna sell it to me and i'm
going to sell it to you i'm going to
bring it here
and you give me i don't know some tools
uh your wife made before the day
uh is this what happened is this how it
was there trade are these people kidding
me
these people don't know anything and
this comes from paleontologists
you got famous when john hawks who says
this nonsense
okay now uh this is this is what the
trade
this is when you trade with a
neanderthal this is what you're going to
get and
if you trade with one today and or in
the future this is what you can expect
okay
this is how a neanderthal trades with
you okay
so if uh if you go in there for the
trade
uh you better be ready for something
else you're gonna be trading your life
in the future okay okay
uh that in a nutshell what i propose
uh one of these days when i have the
time i'm gonna go into more detail and
explain
why money is going to be why money is
going to disappear which is what a lot
of people want to hear
what the process is and before i can get
to that
i need extinction 101 and people don't
want to do extinction 101 because they
know
nothing about extinction 101 they want
to do extinction 102. they just want to
talk about man
because everybody's an expert in
economics out there
everyone and so you can't even talk to
them because they're all expert they
know economics like the back of their
hand they know exactly what's going to
happen and why the government's wrong
and why
they're producing too much money and why
the interest rate is too high and the
job market is so low
they know everything but they know
nothing about extinction
and so i need for someone to tell me
something about extinction because what
i'm saying is that
if money disappears and money is not the
issue the issue is food because with
money we produce food
money food produces it's you plant money
and that's what
what comes out is the potato if you
don't plant that
that dollar no potato
okay and you can say well i've got my
own garden well again you got your
garden but you don't have any protection
you need protection
uh donny uh he says so you need
any protection al capone he needs
he tells you you need protection you
don't have protection
and you say well i have a colt 45 and
who knows uh
smith's wesson you're gonna have to have
a lot of bullets because you're gonna be
fighting a lot of people coming into
your
to share your bounty and you can't go
out there hunting because everybody's
gonna be hunting
and some people will be hunting people
so
be ready for a big problem like uh
uh freeman said martin freeman said or
the lady there who told him says when
you're hungry you're desperate when
you're desperate you do
very weird things